our first full day in Queenstown
and I couldn't work out if my fit was giving
Apres Ski or David Bain
Either way I didn't have time to fk around this morning
cause we are trying to fit in as much as we
possibly can while we're here
and the aim of the fashion game is to wear as
many garments as you possibly can
cause it's like negative 3 degrees
would you believe me if I told you I was wearing 8
9 if you count socks
last time I was here
the gondolas were old and rickety but now they're pretty fancy
and it took us 450 metres
or about 15 feet for my American friends
up the side of a mountain
and the view was breathtaking
we came up here to do the luge
but she was taking a mental health day or something
and after an hour of waiting
we decided just to settle for the virtual luge
And try come back another day
can anybody name an attraction that doesn't
make you exit through the gift shop though?
we headed back down the mountain and into
the township in search of some lunch
and part of my lunch came in liquid form
because I'm currently completely obsessed with mulled wine
Mark my words I'm gonna be trying to perfect this recipe
and then it was time for our second activity of the day
if you were following me a couple of years ago
when I went to Queenstown with my mum
some of these activities will look familiar
We came down for a couple nights
she was working I was tiki touring around by myself
and being the mum that I am
everything I did, all I could think was
“the kids would love that”
by kids I mean the three young ones and my husband
one such activity was the jet boat
I just found this to be so much fun and I knew that they would enjoy it as well
it's a really thrilling experience
as they take you up to 95 kilometres an hour over water that can be
As shallow as 5 centimetres
It’s also a great way to see all the scenery up close
cause they take you up both the Shotover and the Kawarau rivers
and when the guide goes like this
You’d better hold on tight cause you're about
to do a full spin at high speed
I thought Mark was brave for holding his
phone while we spun
because I could never and there's no way
you can escape this ride without leaving
wet and fkn freezing
it's great
one thing about travelling with kids is a couple of activities
really wears them out and to be honest
I'm tired too so pizza on the floor it is